mona vous êtes devant le tribunal
londonien de westminster où se déroulent
les audiences expliquez-nous qu'est-il
reproché à julian assange
il lui est reproché d'avoir publié
révélé des documents confidentiels
concernant les activités est de
l'américaine en irak et en afghanistan
et comme vous l'avez dit je me retrouve
là actuellement devant le tribunal qui
est à proximité de la prison de belles
marches ont été incarcérés julian
assange souvenez vous il est resté près
de plusieurs années en tout cas à
l'ambassade de l'équateur croître et et
il est juste et là il a été arrêté en
avril 2019 il est ici ils risquent 175
ans de prison aux etats-unis c'est la
justice britannique qui va trancher de
savoir si il sera extradé ou non il fait
face à 18 chefs d'accusation et je vous
l'avais dit également un peu plus tôt il
ya eu beaucoup de soutien qui sont
venues des français mais également des
anglais qui sont ici pour demander la
liberté de julian assange le fondateur
de wikileaks je me trouve actuellement
avec camille souffrons qui est
conseiller politique est également
membre du comité de soutien de julian
assange bonjour à vous alors vous avez
fait le voyage de paris jusqu ici pour
soutenir le fondateur de wikileaks
julian agence pourquoi est-ce que
c'était important pour vous de venir
vous êtes venus en nombre aujourd'hui
alors actuellement nous sommes plus de
200 être venus en bus est parfait une
grille en provenance de paris nous avons
aussi des amis de belgique nous avons
des amis d'allemagne beaucoup d'anglais
z anglais aussi qui sont présents pour
deux deux principales raisons
premièrement pour défendre le droit à la
liberté d'expression à la liberté de la
presse à la transparence aujourd'hui
nous avons des états et des pouvoirs
publics qui ont des outils de plus en
plus puissant en termes de surveillance
et il ya un vrai besoin démocratique de
défendre la transparence et de défendre
les lanceurs d'alerté est deuxième et
manqué un peu plus technique mais qui
est vitale et même pour vous mona pour
votre profession c'est que nous sommes
dans un système de common law le droit
anglais et américains c'est à dire c'est
la décision du jld
ce qui crée la loi et le risque c'est
que si une décision est dans le sens de
l'extradition et la condamnation de
julian assange aux états unis cela
risque de faire jurisprudence et donc
d'être une décision qui va être
généralisé pour n'importe quel lanceur
dallaire tout journaliste qui va se
trouver dans cette situation
déjà venu ici ce n'est pas la première
fois que vous venez soutenir le
fondateur de wikileaks où vous êtes venu
déjà une première fois devant la prison
de belmarsh où ils se trouvent tout à
fait en janvier dernier donc c'est la
quatrième édition de ses déplacements
moi c'est la seconde fois où je viens et
notamment nous avons manifesté nous
avons eu confirmation que julian assange
nous a entendu des codétenus ont exprimé
le fait qu'il nous a entendus car il a
plusieurs enfants julia l'enjeu
juridique avec la défense de baltasar
garzon notamment eric dupond moretti en
france il y à aussi mobilisation de
l'opinion publique pour appeler les
états proposé un visa humanitaire
et puis à questions morales julian
assange et à des gros problèmes de santé
dus à l'heure à son enfermement est gêné
jusqu'à récemment était dans un
isolement quasi total de 22 heures sur
24 n'avait pas le droit au sport n'avait
pas d'assistance médicale alors qu'il
avait un abcès dentaire une blessure
sérieuse à l'épaule n'avait pas le droit
à ses lunettes correctrices et donc est
aussi une question humaine de lui
apporter un soutien moral dans ces
moments très difficiles qui sont
assimilées à de la torture par le
rapporteur spécial pour les nations
unies pour la torture nice melzer est ce
que vous êtes optimiste quant à l'avenir
écoutez optimiste il faut l'être pour le
coeur mais ça s'avère compliqué pour
information et donc les stratégies de la
défense tournon évidemment autour de la
santé de la santé donc des gares le fait
que les états unis ne vont pas offrir de
garantie à julian assange pour qu'ils
soient bien traités et en bonne santé
aux états unis
il ya aussi la question autour des
inculpations politique
l'enjeu pour la défense c'est de montrer
que les accusations donc les 18 chefs
d'inculpation invoquée par donald trump
ce sont des accusations politiques et
non pas juridique et le troisième
élément s'est montrée l'imparfaite
l'impossibilité d'avoir un procès
impartial
pourquoi parce que il y à des conflits
d'intérêts on a appris aussi avec la loi
suédoise avec l' affaire de viol qui a
été classé en suède que
des telles que des communications entre
le parquet britannique le parquet
suédois et le fbi et la police fédérale
américaine avait été détruite des
ministres du gouvernement britannique se
sont vantés d'avoir un pouvoir
diplomatique pour envoyer assange en
prison et lui faire sauter l'asile
politique équatorienne donc la
possibilité d'avoir un procès impartial
et très compliqué si beaucoup à vous
pour ce témoignage bon courage à vous
dans votre combat vous l'avez entendu
sophie plusieurs plusieurs soutiens qui
ceux qui affluent ici en grand mot mais
qui viennent un petit peu de tous les
pays des manifestations et des
rassemblements sont organisés dans le
monde entier
en france également ici dans le centre
ville est bien évidemment devant ce
tribunal on ne sait pas exactement ce
qui va se passer à quelle heure ça va se
terminer en tout cas on a vu les avocats
de julian assange s'engouffrer ici
devant ce tribunal et son père étaient
étaient là également il a remercié tous
les soutiens est également l les
journalistes et il a alerté sur les
dangers que que les révélations et
journalistique peuvent entraîner en tout
cas c'est aujourd'hui que la justice
britannique va trancher sur le sort de
génial assange le fondateur de wikileaks
est on sûr à ça avec attention avec vous
mme mohamud est là en direct de londres